on va devoir vous en être question
mémoire zabou on va vous faire une
interview première fois à bouger chez
vous j'ai bougé et orales m
zabou on va vers une interview première
fois dans la bouche pendant l'été
je peux pas les images vous et vous vous
êtes comme des statues j'arrive dur
avant avant qu'il le dise vous avoir
chopé une position qui est confortable
mais c'est comme ça sans me battre ici
ça dure premier exploit à bout premier
mensonge et je m'en souviens pas quelle
année mois première fois où vous avez
fait pleurer votre mère à jeu une fois
elle était venue me coucher et puis je
voulais pas qu'elle s'en aille
je ne voulais pas qu'elle parte je
voulais qu'elle chante encore une
chanson est encore une chanson est
encore une chanson je mettais pondu
literato mouvement à son cou accrochée
et je lui avais fait mal au cou et il
avait pleuré pour première première
belle robe première belle robe
alors pour moi mais vraiment pour moi
petite fille ça a été la panoplie
d'isabelle l'as rome de mama fouda mais
en même temps premiers flirts ces
coiffes laert un roulage de pelle
pilotage du bar tout sujet mélange quoi
avec avec la langue
mon premier flirt alors si vous dites
que c'est ça je les ai épousé c'est lui
oui mais entre temps vous êtes un peu en
trente ans et qui est étonnant c'est
perdu de vue oui vous avez perdu depuis
une dizaine d'années et puis on s'est
retrouvé ce bout du nez c'est très beau
premier chagrin d'amour
oui je me souviens je devais partir en
vacances avec lui et il m'a dit
oh non on me dont il me dit oh non je
partais en vacances je restais au
téléphone comment et pourquoi
et j'ai dit mais la question qu'il faut
absolument pas posée je fais mais euh tu
m'aimes plus est pas dit non mais fait
banon qui a été abolie nabeul première
fois première fois c'était un peu comme
cv quand vous j'avais tellement les
chocottes que c'était un peu comme quand
vous avalez un médicament périmé vie
d'une vie d'un grand verre d'eau c'est
bien expliqué que j'écrivais attrait
d'accord très mais première fois c'était
une première expérience homosexuelle
demain demain dakar première fois à 3
après demain donc je vous demande pas à
quatre par trois jours le doublage
commun
je sais pas si c'est de la sagesse
première cuite
j'ai avoir 15 ans j'avais bu un grand
verger pas contre genre pastis ou un
truc comme ça ou deux qui est malade
comme un chien et je me souviens qu'ils
avaient comme musique de fond
sister jane de campsas hatley de deux de
taï phong qui était le groupe de shaw
d'albums sisto jane et moi
comme un chien avait été épouvantable
premier pétard à la campagne un truc
avait poussé dans jardin d'un mec je
trouvais que c'était mauvais comme vous
et ils étaient tous très bizarre après
et moi je suis fou de joie comme eux
donc ils jouaient tous de la batterie
c'est pas pourquoi il n'y avait pas de
battre bijoux mais tous devant nous il
était hors jeu au placement et de la
batterie et je me suis dit faut sûrement
jouer de la batterie pour comprendre
premier incident dans une semaine
premier valium ah non je n'ai pas prévu
de lexomil
oui j'en ai pris des fois ouais ça m'est
arrivé une ou deux fois incarne ce petit
truc n'est pas très bon justement pour
la mémoire c'est très très justement qui
prennent ça comme ça ça va me calmer
alors c'est pas bon du tout du tout pour
la mémoire
c'est vraiment moche non pour faire
vraiment tout doucement zabou premier
film comme réalisatrice sagement
souvenir oui c'est quoi ces souvenirs de
belles choses